hi steve kaufman here today
i'm going to answer the question
how do you become good at speaking in a
language what's the secret
and i'm going to share with you the
secrets about getting started speaking
in the language and how you continue to
get better and better
speaking in a language
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe and by all means join
me at link which is where i learn
languages now you have all heard me talk
about input i stress input i say you
have to get the language in you
you have to acquire words you have to
let your brain get used to the language
and that's how that's where i spend most
of my time but i do want to speak we all
want to speak that's the goal for most
of us of learning a language we want to
communicate with people we want to
connect with people we want to express
ourselves in the new language so how do
we do it
and people have asked me sort of
specifically to go through sort of step
by step because i know that many of us
and and myself included after a an
extended period of input of listening
and reading it acquiring words and
seeing my comprehension you know improve
and i understand more and more stuff and
then
you know i schedule a session with a
tutor and of course i'm concerned like
how am i going to be able to retrieve
these words you know oh by the way i'm
wearing my t-shirt from machu picchu and
it relates a little bit to my story and
i'll get to that at any rate
you know what happens when we start
speaking how do we get started and
that's what i want to kind of cover in
this video sort of getting started
speaking in a language and then doing
all the things you need to do so that
you can continue to get better and
better
even as you continue all of your
input activities even as you continue to
acquire words and phrases and
and and
get your brain used to the new language
so you all know that i spent most of my
time on link
on link of course we have all of our
input activities we also have tutors we
don't have as many tutors as italki but
we do have some
and the advantage at link is that the
tutors report is incorporated into link
so i have a record all of all of my
conversations with my tutors now
in persian
i'll give you an example so persian and
arabic both very difficult because the
writing system is so difficult so what i
did in order to break down that first
barrier in other words i have never said
anything in persian or arabic how do i
get started how do i get words out now
there are people who say that you can
talk to yourself and you can say phrases
to yourself
but i've never found that i'm able to do
that for very long i might try it but i
won't spend a lot of time doing it it's
just something that i have never been
able to do people who can do it good for
them it's a way for them to prime the
pump to get started what i found and
what i recommend
what i found very useful was
in languages like persian and arabic
especially but probably in all languages
i get a tutor whether on link or
italki and i say i want to read
and what and i i want to then talk about
what i have read and what i use as the
sort of material that's going to prime
the pump and get me going is the mini
stories because the many stories have so
much repetition built into each story
and i end up listening to each one of
them 10 20 30 times not necessarily at
one sitting but over the course of a
couple of months i will have listened to
lesson one two three four five back to
lesson one and so i'm familiar with
what's there and in each mini story
there are questions but the questions
are structured in such a way that you
are given the answer in other words a
statement you are asked the question
about that statement
and then
you are given the answer so you don't
even have to provide the answer it's
just more exposure but now with my tutor
i'm asked those questions and i have to
produce the answer but i am producing an
answer that i already know that i have
listened to many many times so
the big thing about speaking is to
reduce stress if there's one key it's to
reduce stress stephen krashen says that
we learn languages when there is
meaningful communication in a low stress
or unstressful environment or situation
so anything you can do to reduce stress
is going to help you
so first of all
if you have a tutor you're with someone
who is paid
to speak to you so that's less stressful
than hoping that some random person you
meet is going to want to humor you in
your in the language you're learning so
that reduces stress
even amongst the tutors some are more
sympathetic than others some make a face
if you say something wrong or show
impatience you don't want those tutors
you want the tutor that's very
encouraging doesn't correct you all the
time
and keeps the conversation going
but also
by
sort of having a
pseudo conversation where i'm asked
questions that i have heard before
and where i have in fact read the story
with the tutor and maybe even read some
of the questions and then i'm asked the
question i have the answer i'm not asked
to remember something about the story
i'm just asked to say something that
i've heard before and
you know is very familiar to me i'm
likely to succeed whenever you're given
something to do where you're likely to
succeed that's good
the brain likes it likes success doesn't
like failure so i find that beginning to
speak in a language
reading and then discussing
using the questions that are in the many
stories is extremely helpful and so i
would recommend that as a sort of step
number one where you you got to break
the ice you've got to go from all of
your listening and reading to
to a situation where you're starting to
speak and what i found in both arabic
and persian was that
i would do that for three or four five
six lessons and then i was tired of
doing that now i wanted to even within
the 60 minutes i might do that for the
first 20 minutes and then i would start
to wander off into something else
perhaps using the vocabulary that i had
learned so it's i'm sliding into sort of
a broader range of you know exchange
with my tutor all in a low stress
environment so that's extremely
important the next thing is
obviously when you start to speak part
of the stress comes from your inability
to say what you want to say part of it
comes from not understanding what the
other person is saying because you're
not good enough in the language to have
a really good free-flowing conversation
a bit of advice don't worry about what
you can't say
don't worry about what you don't
understand and there is a bit of a
tendency for people to
wonder about what
people are saying like i often people
ask me well have you ever been in an
elevator with asian people and have they
said stuff about you never people don't
talk about you but it's when you don't
understand you conjure up these ideas
that people are talking about you or
what are they saying and and i've often
as i'm progressing in a language when i
was learning portuguese i'm with these
brazilians and they're all talking a
mile a minute and
i feel i should be able to understand
but i don't understand because my brain
is not yet used to it you have to
remember that with enough exposure you
will get better and so every time you're
in a situation where you don't
understand or you can't say what you
want to say that's fine it's part you're
on your way that's part of the process
uh of getting to know you know
acquiring a language and when i was in
machu picchu i was with these other
people and our guide was speaking to me
in different languages and they were a
little bit annoyed that the guide wasn't
speaking in english they were annoyed
that they couldn't understand what what
he was saying
don't worry about what you can't
understand that's very important so
begin with the mini stories reading
answering questions where you have the
answers where you've actually heard the
answers many many times then gradually
move to subjects which are of greater
interest to you but i
would recommend staying with people who
are paid to be sympathetic to you like a
tutor or a teacher of some kind
uh if you like i mentioned when i was
learning japanese i had a very patient
assistant
mr nick yazaki who was very long-winded
and spoke very you know
humored me and stuff if you have people
like that fine but don't put yourself in
stressful situations then just keep on
speaking
keep on uh
finding and there again find a tutor
who's good at keeping you going who can
ask you questions about things that
you're interested in where you're going
to succeed who doesn't insist on you
know like i've had tutors that they just
they want to talk about food i don't
know the words for food and let's say
persian i want to talk about history
which is of interest to me but my tutor
she didn't want to talk about history so
get tutors that are sympathetic that
don't express annoyance when you make
mistakes
and who are good at keeping the
conversation going around things that
you are interested in and where you can
express yourself and then
of course when i get my
conversation report at link i study it i
listen to it many times
and i remember the things that i had
trouble saying
and if i look at a number of these
conversation reports and listen to them
i realize that i made the same mistakes
week after week after week it doesn't
matter you have to have confidence that
you are gradually going to improve so
the answer how do you
get started speaking and continue to
improve reduce the stress reduce the
stress start with
something like the many stories where
you're basically
reproducing things that you have heard
many many times and from there gradually
wander into a greater range of subjects
subjects that are of interest to you
with someone who is sympathetic to you
and you know gradually your ability to
speak will improve and in the end as
i've said many times even though i
stress input
to speak well you have to speak a lot so
that
i find that i'm speaking with a tutor
once or twice a week you know at the
early stages maybe three months after i
started into the language but eventually
if i want to do well in the language i
may eventually have to go to the country
but i also ramp up
you know my my
sessions with my tutor maybe four or
five times a week so
there you have it my take on how to get
proficient at speaking which is
something we all want to do and how do
we do it in a way that minimizes stress
and i'll leave you with a couple of
videos that might be relevant to you on
the subject okay then bye for now